hello and welcome to this video croc em
let's see what he wants to do here we
are what do we get I really need to do
something about my squad repertoire oh
you should be Johanna doesn't really put
a big scare on to black but it is a very
playable move so what to do something
like g6 maybe Bishop c5 you will
probably play and he will probably play
the m95 idea wow that's really not rest
on an aggressive setup but ok certainly
playable preventing the pin ok I'm going
to play a play into a closed position
something that um when I say a position
type that I have played quite a bit hi
this actually he has he SD form I should
have thought about this a little bit
more yeah five is not a great move him d
4 was a good one but ok it's not a big
deal
[Music]
Bishop a 3 was a bit unexpected what is
he doing him okay I was threatening
Bishop h3 okay so I'm just stepping out
of it okay that's interesting isn't this
nice i I'm ready for a 5 m and this I'm
going to block I'm not going to allow
you to place you find not not on my
watch after take care here now if I go
f5 yes Bishop h5 should not blunder into
that oh I could have taken you for here
maybe was my queen trapped why can I not
take this I think I can and then for big
Center porn I'm willing to move the
Queen a couple of times I could have
taken this mover Liam and should have
taken a little earlier
centerpoint is too much I'm not
threatening bishop age three year though
he has Bishop e3 in reply yeah he needs
to initiate some kind of play okay so if
i take this is going to play d 6 okay i
really don't need this I can play this
movement go for 94 for example depends
on his reply now but that's a bishop a 3
in this night yeah auntie I can just
take it or go here before it's actually
interesting let's do this those points
come up the board really quickly now
[Music]
we're looks awful maybe g3 em Jim stop
me from well I create okay between g5
this one yeah I can take F to hear but
he's got look II tune so let's not do
that
but I think it's still nice I'm
attacking f2 now what's what's going on
your f form you don't get it
don't see a big big scare you think I'm
just going to take it next quite
resigned yeah okay so somehow i don't
get all to examine here you have to and
i'll restart my software now yeah i paid
one really silly movie at this age 9 h 7
yeah here there are a couple of options
i can also play d 5 which is maybe the
most principled one but i was looking
more for a closed kind of tradition this
is basically ok but i don't think with
hindsight that this is such a good idea
after d4 I mean I was intending a5 quite
clearly but he and five my center is
just shaking you know that that's just
not good ok so I went for him let's see
normal moves we should pay three I found
surprising and this is him dd5 I feel is
wrong that should give me a nice
position the bishop simply don't do that
much in that closed position and I'm
still quite ready for a five this one
yeah that's not doing much shown this an
f5 yeah this is so this position is
perfectly fine ma'am this engine gives
me a slight advantage here yeah well
this is maybe it's just a slight
advantage but I mean this is extremely
comfortable for black now this pawn
structure remains bad for white and I
have the FRS and very good pollution and
I should just take euphoria that was it
was kind of an automatic reaction but I
can just take this pawn
like I did one move for move later right
has absolutely no compensation okay I
could have taken c4 as well you don't
eat you can just convert from you on T
trapped his own rook but that was
already pretty much beyond repair okay
thanks for watching